nous sommes aujourd'hui dans la cour de
la ferme qui a servi de cadre au
tournage du film c'est en effet ici en
1967 qui robert le célèbre réalisateur
de la guerre des boutons avait donc
choisi de poser ses caméras
andré legrand avait 13 ans à l'époque du
tournage il faisait partie des figurants
on va le retrouver dans un instant avec
lui on va évoquer les souvenirs du
tournage mais d'abord comme d'habitude
les archives dans un charmant village
des environs de chartres yves robert
tonnes actuellement alexandre le
bienheureux avec dans les principaux
rôles françoise briand et philippe
noiret alexandre est un homme qui a
découvert qu une des sources du bonheur
pourrait bien être l'oise yves t la
grande sa femme n'est pas du tout du
même avis pour elle le bonheur ce serait
plutôt le rendement à l'hectare va faire
un petit les visions a demandé le cinéma
je ferai un truc télévision
est il possible de résumer ce scénario
déficit parce que c'est une espèce de
conte le thème en gros l'histoire d'un
homme qui cherche à liberté à travers
l'agitation du monde paysan est aussi
une agitation d'une agitation partout et
qui trouve quand même sa liberté malgré
les hommes et surtout les femmes
bonjour andré legrand on joue alors je
le disais vous aviez 13 ans à l'époque
du tournage du film et on peut le dire
vous avez vécu une formidable aventure
vous êtes un enfant du pays vous êtes né
à lui vous vivez toujours ici mais
d'abord ça vous fait quoi de revoir
comme ça yves robert ça nous rappelle
mon enfance et ak-47 en deçà et puis du
des vacances que jamais jamais imaginer
quoi
gens comme ça à venir tourner un film à
lui c'était pendant l'été c'était
pendant l'été où est à peu près six ou
sept semaines l'été sauf qu'un jour où
il était parti faire en studio à bowling
vous allez nous expliquer comment vous
vous êtes retrouvé dans cette aventure
incroyable mais d'abord un premier
extrait du film alexandre le bienheureux
c'est philippe noiret on l'a dit c'est
un agriculteur il travaille beaucoup
parce que sa femme est bien lui impose
des cadences un peu infernal on regarde
on en parle juste après la coopérative
prend de l'engrais ensuite retourné le
branchant des maisons neuves
non ne pas s'arrêter pour regarder non
les longueurs d'écart
non allez alors la suite du film il va
se passer un événement dans la vie d'
alexandre le bienheureux dans la vie peu
philippe noiret et c'est justement
philippe noiret qui raconte la suite aux
journalistes de centre actualité venue
l'interviewer sur le tournage du film on
regarde françoise plutôt la grande un
accident de voiture et alexandre se
trouve libéré à ce qu'on a c'est à dire
qu'ils en profitent pour vivre comme ils
rêvaient de le faire depuis longtemps
c'est à dire ne rien faire ils se
couchent d'abord pendant très longtemps
et il va faire le paresseux dans cette
chambre située dans la ferme c'était a
été tourné ici
non tous les intérieurs ont été tournées
au studio de boulogne
à la ferme on voit que les extérieurs
alors parlons vous je le disais vous
aviez 13 ans vous étiez un tout jeune
garçon
comment vous êtes retrouvés dans cette
aventure yves robert avait fait passer
un mot à l'école comme quoi il avait
besoin de figurants et on est surmonté
tous se retrouver à la salle des fêtes
il a déjà choisi tout un tas de bercy et
fille qui était blond et faire un
familles sont rien on leur a donné des
lunettes seront les retombées tous
l'appellent encore le joint de quelques
figures ont donc eu non plus et on a
participé alors on va vous voir dans ce
film andré on va voir quelques scènes
notamment cette partie de football avec
philippe noiret regardez et vous en
parlais juste après
et
robert n'appelle du bon ben voilà dd on
va donner le ballon quand tu dribbles
différents organes on est assez proches
les avait 13 ans donc tout allait bien
angie sur tous vos potes marque deux
buts à philippe tu t'approches c'est lui
qui doit l'arrêter comme nous tous
trouve que c'est un bon gardien de but
donc je fais tout ce qui me demandent
mes philippe carette est tellement grand
par rapport à -14 baisse quand attaquer
le ballon une prend le pied avec et je
fais une roulade par dessus son épaule
yves robert excellent on coupe on
recommence et cela fait quatre ou cinq
fois au wahoo dans le film aussi bon bah
on aperçoit quand je surfe en choeur
aussi bien à l'enterrement au mariage
on voit un peu plus quand on est dans la
ferme je suis à côté de la carriole et
j'envoie le gamin binôme chercher
alexandre y revient en courant parce que
bien qu'ils courent après et ont aussi à
leur site à la sortie de l'école c'est
moi le meneur qui dit aux copains on a
tous et végétation demain on fait comme
alexandre vous êtes allés à la
projection accordé dès qu'il est sorti
le lendemain et surlendemain grâce à un
fork habitait à paris je suis allé le
voir à paris
et la semaine d'après quand il est sorti
au rex à chartres il ya vu un transport
par cars d'organiser et on était une
cinquantaine est allé voir le film
chartres c'était ordinaire merci en tout
cas d'avoir retrouvé la mémoire en notre
compagnie et nous on se dit à bientôt